Хоча будівництво морської ділянки "Турецького потоку"
завершено, газ по ньому запущено поки не буде.
Ще немає компресорної станції і не готова
наземна частина магістралі, тож церемонія
у Стамбулі 19 листопада за участю Путіна та Ердогана
має виключно символічний характер.
При цьому "Турецький потік" сприймають у ЄС
не так критично, як інший газпромівський проект -
"Північний потік-2".
- Не так критично, тому що не можна
порівнювати обсяги поставок. Сумарна потужність
першої і другої черг "Північного потоку" - 110 мільярдів кубометрів газу на рік.
А дві гілки "Турецького потоку" - це трохи більше 31 мільярда.
Крім того, через Туреччину на Захід проходять
і інші газопроводи. "Турецький потік" - лише один із них.
Рішення побудувати "Турецький потік"
було багато в чому вимушеним. Ця магістраль
прийшла на зміну амбітному проекту
"Південний потік", яким "Газпром" хотів
постачати газ до Євросоюзу в обхід України.
Москва мріяла протягнути трубу в Болгарію,
Але тоді не вдалося узгодити цей проект
із Брюсселем, і в підсумку Путін оголосив про його згортання.
Замість Болгарії було вирішено домовитися
з Туреччиною, яка не входить у ЄС.
Але потужність магістралі довелося скоротити
навпіл: не 63 мільярди кубометрів на рік, а тільки 31 з половиною.
Замість чотирьох ниток залишилися тільки дві.
Лише одну з них "Газпром" заклав із розрахунком на Євросоюз.
- За планом, перша нитка "Турецького потоку"
призначена для заміщення експорту газу до Туреччини через Україну.
І тільки по другій гілці потужністю трохи більше 16 мільярдів кубометрів
на рік газ може піти в Італію.
Ці обсяги може втратити основний транзитер
російського газу - Україна.
У Москві на це і роблять ставку,
однак поки що це лише загроза, адже
жодних конкретних домовленостей
ані з Італією, ані з Євросоюзом поки немає.
- Доля другої нитки абсолютно невідома: куди вона
повинна піти і як вона вийде з Туреччини в бік ЄС.
Узгодження з Єврокомісією немає.
Так само, як не було і по "Південному потоку".
Узгодження не було, але "Газпром"
почав будувати цей нещасний "Південний потік",
від якого в грудні 2014 року довелося відмовитися.
І ось ця друга нитка поки впирається в стіну...
Вартість будівництва власне "Турецького потоку"
оцінюється в 7 мільярдів євро. Однак якщо додати
до цієї суми мільярди, витрачені на нереалізований
"Південний потік", рентабельність проекту
починає викликати в експертів значні сумніви.
- Він узагалі ніколи не окупиться. Коли будували
"Південний потік", тобто по території Росії
прокладали труби в бік Чорного моря,
щоб був "Південний потік", чотири нитки
планувалося. Зараз тільки дві залишилося.
Проклали величезну кількість труб,
і всі витрати на це оцінюються в 17 мільярдів доларів.
Якщо "Газпром" не виконає вимоги Брюсселя
або Євросоюз відмовиться купувати газ, що
надходить по "Турецькому потоку",
проект точно можна буде вважати провальним.
Шанс узгодити з ЄС поставки по другій нитці ще є.
Але з огляду на те, що "Газпром" планує запустити
"Турецький потік" до кінця 2019 року, часу на те, щоб
домовитися з ЄС, залишається обмаль.